right the eagles the eagles have a
situation that many fans would say are
not right they still don't understand
why the team would use a second round
pick on quarterback jaylen hertz uh they
think it was wasted they think that you
know there's some who would think oh
they have a plan now to supplant carson
wentz i mean look carson wentz is their
guy carson wentz is their franchise but
they understand that you have to have a
good backup quarterback because carson
white is a guy who gets injured from
time to time and carson wentz spoke to
the media yesterday these teams have
been making players available through
video conference which which is good
because if there were off-season
programs players would periodically be
available to the media during the
off-season workouts so i appreciate the
fact that the teams are making these
guys available carson wentz had a lot of
interesting things to say yesterday and
one of the things he spoke about was
concussion symptoms he and i remember
chris four years ago when he was
entering the nfl out of north dakota
state
and i had him on this show
and asked him about his concern as it
relates to concussions because he had
had multiple that he knew about playing
at north dakota state you come to the
nfl your likelihood of getting
concussions is going to go up because
you're getting hit by bigger stronger
faster individuals he said yesterday of
the concussion he suffered against the
seattle seahawks in the postseason when
he took that hit from geneva and clowney
that hit that should have been flagged
and should have been fined but wasn't he
said it's scary stuff it kind of changes
a lot of things in your brain you only
get one of these brains you got to
protect it it was tough to see the
finish of that game that was the end of
our season it was frustrating not to be
out there but that's exactly what
happened when when clowney went in head
first when he took that that that shot
at carson wentz and got him out of the
game and you know they don't talk about
that anymore it's the bounty scandal and
it creates all sorts of issues and
problems that the nfl tries to make the
game safer and safer but every time i
see that hit
look i don't know how much that was
coached chris but you got a free shot at
the quarterback and there were plenty of
guys in the nfl who were going to take
it and that's what clowney did and he
should have been fined he should have
been flagged and and and the eagles
being as pragmatic and realistic as
possible about this you have to account
for the chances is going to happen
that's why you have jalen hurts because
you never know when something like
that's going to happen and you can't
have a 40 some year old josh mccown as
your option in the post season when
you're trying to advance to the next
level i love josh mccown but you gotta
have something something better as your
backup plan in that situation
yeah well you know you know the way
carson wentz plays to your point with
the gideon clowny thing you know guys
their their eyes light up when they play
carson wins you know they know they're
going to get a chance to for lack of a
better way to say give the guy the
business a little bit you know when
you're a quarterback in the open field
man defenders are going to do anything
they can to just give you a little extra
whatever put the head down let me smash
his head into the ground kind of like
which debbie young clown he did carson
wentz plays a dangerous style of
football so the eagles got to protect
themselves i understand that they have
nate sutfeld certainly you know this is
not about a threat to carson wentz it's
not but he does need to learn to adjust
his style of play he was better last
year no doubt but it's got to continue
to improve mike i could show you you
know an old video i made a bleacher
report after carson wentz got drafted
you know one of the things i emphasized
the thing and you said this already the
thing that scared me the number one
scare i had of carson wentz was injury
it was a lot like i'm not going to say
it was as bad as two of this year but i
was worried about you mentioned the
concussions the way he played in college
football at north dakota state man he
was lowering his shoulder and taken a
lot of huge car collision type hits
where i just went wow this guy is he's
not going to make it if he does this
crap in the nfl and we've seen it's
taken a toll on him now i understand the
eagles fans being a little frustrated
with the jalen hurts draft pick you know
one i don't again carson wentz
solidified himself last year as a guy on
the verge of one of the five best
quarterbacks in football i don't think
anybody's gonna sit here and argue that
he is in somewhere six between six and
ten with what he did and the team that
he carried on his back the last five six
seven weeks of the year no weapons
around him
not a great run game and he just made it
happen he's special that way so this is
not a
oh gosh we drafted jalen hurts you
should feel threatened carson once no
this is an insurance policy for the
philadelphia eagles along with able
being able to use the skill set of jalen
hurts to help out the weaponry of the
the offense of the philadelphia eagles
and and you just have to be ready for
anything that can happen especially when
you have a quarterback with that
physical style who at this point is not
going to change that's the reality this
many years into your football career
from high school to college to the nfl
you're not going to change your style
you have a greater risk of injury than
say a pocket passer would uh like a tom
brady and i you know i i spoke to bill's
gm brandon bean about this last week
when uh talking about their decision to
use a fifth round pick on on jake fromm
right you've got a starter and josh
allen who plays a physical style of
football you have to have a backup plan
in place because you never know when
you're going to have to use it we
mentioned josh mccown
i think the mural at dwayne haskins
house it looks more like josh mccown
than tom brady that's very definitely
it's more of a joshua count chin for
sure josh mccown has that chin you were
talking about
it's like some it's like he does
exercises for it it's the greatest jaw
i've ever seen
so i'm with you you know but mike i will
say this
i do think carson wentz played a safer
brand of football last year i do you
know i thought there was a number of
games where
i went and years past i think he tries
to fight for a yard or two that last
year he just went down and slid it's not
perfect but i do think he has made an
effort to
you know take that part of his game out
or at least he is trying to lessen it to
a degree and we saw that i mean he
played healthy football all year last
year he got hurt in the worst possible
time uh but i i do think he's making an
effort is all i'm saying i don't know if
he'll ever be perfect to your point but
i think he is conscious of it and he
realizes that it's it's hurt his career
the the fact that he hasn't been
available has hurt his career to this
point
general manager howie roseman called
carson wentz before selecting jalen
hurts with the 53rd overall pick in the
draft roseman has described the
conversation as quote not comfortable
end quote because of the needs the team
had at the other positions that means
wence said
kind of like what an owner in green bay
if there was one would have said to
brian goodacoon's before selecting
jordan love
have you lost your mind we have needs we
have guys who are going to be on the
field that can help us win why are you
drafting a quarterback who ideally won't
be on the field but the thing is
with carson wentz you have to account
for that possibility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports